so this is just like my experience with
self-love like girls that spout this
it's like usually just a okay to be
delusional and like kind of outpace
where they're actually at in life like
for example they'll say oh I did like I
love myself I like I don't deserve I'm
I'm gonna reject these guys like I'm
above them in some way are they kind of
insinuate that's the thing right but but
to me it's like if those are the guys
that are approaching you and interested
in you that's that's what you deserve
because that's what you're worth it's
like what you're like how could I say
like if I'm if I don't get offered a job
that's a hundred thousand dollars how
can I say oh I'm worth a hundred
thousand dollars but girls will be like
Oh I'm 300 pounds but I'm worth a guy
that makes six figures and is six feet
tall and is all this stuff but if you
don't have those men approaching you
like how do you how can you say you
deserve them